it's not as picturesque as the famous
Taj Mahal but this has become one of the
images synonymous with India and not one
that Donald Trump was taken to see these
people are among the growing numbers of
India's homeless aid agencies estimate
that three million people are living on
the streets throughout the country
200,000 of them in the capital Delhi
there's a world of poverty exploitation
and abuse and India has the highest
number of street children in the world
life is very complex and difficult for
them like particularly for children
living in a street situation we have
found that many of them have exposure to
how the risk that will have impact on
them for lifetime by the time Donald
Trump was 8 years old he was worth a
million dollars most of these children
are around the same age some don't even
own a pair of shoes but they have hopes
I want to be a policeman so people who
respect us I want to be a doctor and buy
a house maybe a car that's unlikely to
happen without support they and their
families survive by begging or working
menial jobs
what can I think of the future I just
want my daughter to grow up for her to
be educated and one day that she will
have her own home that's all in some
respects at least life for children in
India is improving infant mortality
rates for example have been drastically
cut in the last 10 years but in terms of
education it's not so good and an
estimated 80 million children don't go
to school education is important to
ending the cycle of poverty this is a
free school set up under busy Delhi
flyover by volunteer teachers it's aimed
at helping kids of poor families as it
was earlier people who are not educated
are treated like animals by society but
with education they learn about their
rights and they can use them to benefit
their lives
it's a small chance but better than
nothing these sisters home is a Shack
without water and electricity their
parents work menial jobs they see the
school as a way to a better world I want
to be a doctor when I grow up so I can
help people I want to help my parents
and sisters 300 children attend the
school under the bridge most don't know
about President Donald Trump the Indian
Prime Minister Narendra Modi said it's
his dream that everyone in India will
have a home by 2022 that seems
impossible
on the streets of New Delhi the dreams
are more basic so Ghana is nine years
old she's lived on the streets most of
her life and all she wants if she had
money she says is to buy food India has
just spent 3 billion dollars on u.s.
military helicopters it is a nuclear
power with an expensive program for
space exploration but many here say it
is not yet been able to find a way to
take care of its poor and helpless
Tony Berkeley al Jazeera Delhi